- [Voiceover] In the video on the sodium-potassum pump,
we talk about how it helps a cell establish its
resting membrane potential.
And it does that by pumping, actively pumping,
three sodium ions out for every two potassium ions
it pumps in, and that by itself, that ratio of three to two
by itself doesn't establish the full
resting membrane potential, but then
the potassium ions are allowed to start
diffusing down their concentration gradient
from the inside back to the outside.
And of course there's a balancing force there,
or a balancing factor, and that's the charge.
Because if the outside is more positive than the inside,
a positively-charged ion, which the potassium ions are,
well, they're not gonna want to go up here so much
because of their charge.
It's more positive here than it is over here.
They'd actually want to go back, but their concentration
gradient, they're going to be bumping into the bottom
of this channel more than the top,
and so you're going to have a balance.
They're going to start diffusing through,
but you're not going to have equal concentrations
because the charge is going to keep them back here.
But what about the sodium ions?
The sodium ions are getting more and more
concentrated up here, and up here is getting
more and more positive.
If the sodium ions were left to their own devices,
if there was no membrane over here, they
would naturally, if we just looked at the concentration
gradient, they would naturally want to diffuse down.
We have a high concentration over here,
we have a low concentration over there.
So if there was no membrane, then they would just naturally
diffuse from high to low.
That's their concentration gradient.
And also if there was no membrane, we've
already talked about it being much more positive
on this side than it is on this side.
Or you could say we have a positive potential difference
between here and here.
So the positively charged ions, like the sodiums up here,
would want to go down because of their charge.
And so there's two reasons why they would want
to go from this side of the membrane to that side
of the membrane.
Their concentration gradient and their charge,
the electric potential.
There's this potential energy of them wanting
to get away from all the positive charges.
And so that combined motivation for the
sodium ions to go in that direction, we call that
the electrochemical gradient.
Electrochemical
gradient.
And I already said it once, but I'll say it again.
It's a combination of the electric gradient and
the chemical gradient.
The chemical gradient, you have higher concentration
here, lower here, you would want to diffuse down,
more things are going to bump on this side
than on this side, so you're going to have a net flow down,
if you didn't have this membrane here.
And then when you think about the electric potential,
more positive on this side than on this side,
so positive ions would want to go down.
And so you could view this gradient as a source
of potential energy.
And cells, in fact, use this gradient,
in fact, the sodium electrochemical gradient as
a source of energy.
And so let's say this protein
right over here, this is what we're going to
call a symporter.
This is a symporter.
And what it does is, it uses the electrochemical
gradient of one ion, in this case sodium,
so it uses the fact that sodium really wants to
go through the membrane, and it uses that energy.
Imagine like water falling down a waterfall
and it can turn a turbine or turn a water mill
type of thing.
And so it uses that energy of the sodium
flowing down its electrochemical gradient,
it wants to go in this direction for two reasons,
concentration and electric potential, or I guess
you'd say its electrostatic charge, and then it
uses that energy to transport other things.
And the most famous symporter with sodium
is glucose.
It's going to use that, the sodium and the glucose
are going to go together.
And the glucose is being transported
against its concentration gradient.
And so if you're going to transport something
against its concentration gradient, you're going to
have to use active transport.
So this concentration gradient, so let me
be clear on glucose's concentration gradient,
it looks like this.
You have high concentration over here and you have
low right over here.
And the cell might not want to waste all this glucose,
it wants to get as much glucose into the cell,
or across the membrane, as possible.
And so it's going to have to do some active transport
to go against its concentration gradient.
To go in this direction.
And over here, the source of energy
to go against the concentration gradient,
is the stored potential energy from the
electrochemical gradient of the sodium.
And so this type of active transport, where you're
using the energy that was stored up through another
form of active transport, the sodium-potassium pump,
we call this Secondary Active Transport.
So what's going over here, this sodium-glucose
symporter, this is Secondary Active Transport.
Secondary Active Transport.
It's using the stored energy from the
electrochemical gradient of one molecule, it's
using that stored energy to drive the active transport
of another molecule, glucose, going against
its concentration gradient.